[Music]
today I'm going to talk to you about one
of the components in one of our
pipelines to create an illustration an
example of the way that data engineering
and machine learning and actually the
configuration of the cluster all three
pieces work together in an ecosystem
that creates successful projects a
little bit about me I've been in the
startup space for a little over five
years and I spent well over ten years
running cosmological simulations on some
of the biggest computers in the country
this is this image is an image from one
of those simulations that's not an image
of an actual galaxy and I spent all this
time learning a lot of skills that I had
no idea would apply to industry
currently I'm working in the commercial
real estate space this space this is one
image of what commercial real estate
looks like commercial real estate is
essentially everything that isn't a
single-family residence so we're talking
agricultural land small malls offices
vacant land across the country to build
products for this space we first think
about how humans interact with these
physical structures humans work and rent
in these buildings they own them they
build them or they fix them whether
they're in construction or roofing they
manage buildings they maintain them and
they see them as components of a larger
picture if they're doing City Planning
if they're studying the US market
so once we understand the types of
interactions that people have with
structures we think about what
information is necessary to support
these human interactions when you're
designing a database you think about the
primary use cases and you defined the
structures in the database to optimize
for delivering those use cases where now
the industry is moving towards a space
where instead of creating these flat
schemas we're creating knowledge graphs
and the knowledge graphs create even
more flexibility for different product
use cases and actually the closer that
the structures are to the structures in
the graph are to reality the more
flexibility you have in defining the
products and supporting different types
of products ok so the information that
we need to understand the world of
commercial real estate really falls into
just a few buckets right so the
properties themselves and the structures
that live on those properties the
history of the structure the hist the
financial history the mortgage history
the debt history the owners ownership
history we want to know the people that
are associated with that structure and
we want to know the companies that are
associated with the structures and the
people and all of these components
together create property intelligence
currently the majority of information in
the commercial real estate space is not
just flat but it's sort in paper so
there are not very many available
sources of fully connected data so the
things that we're building are are quite
unusual and quite powerful because of
their flexibility and because they're so
different from the status quo
okay so this is a cartoon of a graph of
this is a cartoon of our graph and there
are I say cartoon because it doesn't
exactly capture our graph structure
there's some domain-specific components
that are not a necessary part of this
talk but if you look at the structure
you can see how you could query the
graph to get an idea of what properties
live within ownership portfolio of this
company if you wanted to look at
management you could query the graph
information in a different way to find
the people who are managing the
different properties if you are looking
to find the ultimate owner of a company
you can traverse take multiple steps up
through the graph to find - from parent
company to parent company and serve all
of the use cases that we talked about
before people who all in the buildings
who work in the buildings manage the
buildings people who want it fix the
buildings okay so which pieces of these
structures have machine learning we use
machine learning to define the
information that lives within the
property vertices themselves so we
create unique IDs for each of the
properties we have a host of addresses
and a huge number of fields that belong
to each of these vertices we also use
machine learning to stitch the property
together property data together with a
company data to create these ownership
edges
how we use a machine learning to define
the vertices or the company vertices so
all the information that belongs to a
particular company vertex we use machine
learning to create the edges between the
different companies we use machine
learning to define the person vertices
and we use machine learning to take the
context from the properties themselves
and correct and supplement the
information that dwells in these
property vertices
so there's a lot here there are a lot of
models there are a lot of different
pipelines there are a lot of jobs that
go into building these structures what
we'll focus on today is just one
particular type of edge it's the edge
that goes from our property vertices to
our company vertices as with everything
you start with the data so we have more
than 50 million commercial property
vertices and then we have more than 80
million verdict business vertices you
could say Maureen they're only 330
million businesses in the United States
about and the 80 million number goes
back to when I mentioned that you have
to have some domain-specific knowledge
around how companies work DBAs LLC's etc
work that increases this number so to
create create the connections you're
essentially drawing a connection between
a row in the commercial property vert
vertex data set and the business vertex
data set comparing all of the data on
one side against all the other data on
the other side blows up blows up our
data set obviously so if you look at
take a lean cut of just the data that
you need you end up with like 50
terabytes of data and then when you blow
it up into all the features that you
need for a model to make a good decision
you're looking at over 100 terabytes of
data and that is just too much data to
run through model and get a turn around
in less than a day for even an even a
pretty large spark cluster so so what do
you do in this type of situation all
right so so what you do is you have
multiple phases in your pipeline to
whittle down
amount of data that you're dealing with
you you start with so you have a very
large amount of data there's a very
small number of positive classes that
you're looking for within the data the
first step is do some kind of blocking
algorithm it could be an adaptive
blocking algorithm there are many
different methodologies for for blocking
ones that essentially all of them create
blocking index and the intention is that
you have very fast in some cases simple
computations that are very high recall
so the idea is to do it is to do it fast
and keep it as simple as you can and to
capture all of the positive classes that
you could feed into the model but you're
playing a game where you're trying to
cut down the incoming data as much as
you can so that this decreases the
amount of data that you feed into the
second step which is your high precision
model at this point you can blow up the
you can blow up the data into the number
of features that you need to get that
you need to get high high accuracy high
precision for this model possibly the
model also needs to be needs to be fast
so the decisions that you make for the
algorithms that you choose for the model
it has to live within the pipeline right
you can't just choose the highest memory
model you can't just write it's these
things can't exist in a vacuum and be
successful they have to be informed by
the pipeline by the volume of data by
the problem ok so and at the end of at
the end of these things so you've got so
four out of the adaptive blocking
algorithm you get many blocks of
potential edges and then out of the
model the model defines the edges and it
defines the strengths of the edges and
that gives you the component of your
graph going back to what the data itself
looks like right we have our commercial
property data and then
we have our business data and you start
out by distributing it evenly on the
cluster simple right totally simple
except that even keeping things as
simple as possible
these adaptive blocking algorithms are
playing like a a very they're playing a
difficult game that is kind of a sly
valence so you're you want to traverse
the data and not just column wise to not
just compare the like with like
components but if you can traverse it
diagonally across the schema which means
that you are going to try to play a game
with your block size right so your block
size is going to be as large as you can
could possibly get it but also small
enough to fit within the cluster so this
sets constraints on the configuration of
the cluster you you wouldn't create the
cluster in a in a way that you would if
you were just creating metrics so you
want to have larger machines compute
efficient large machines so that you can
have larger block sizes so they are not
running out of memory on the on the
individual partitions and you actually
want to have a smaller partitions I mean
still large but a smaller partition size
and then you normally than you normally
would necessarily because the data moves
from looking like this to looking
something like this and it's obviously
very skewed you are there's obviously
like a lot of shuffling that has
happened and this state is is not a good
state necessarily to to feed into a
model so you've you've accommodated the
blocking with add it with a certain with
certain cluster config with certain
instance types if you're using AWS which
we are
and you a certain partition size the
models that we've chosen for this
component are very highly parallelizable
so to get from this bad state to a
better state we just blow out the number
of partitions that we just have an
enormous number of partitions and then
the data is very evenly distributed and
it it blows through the model really
really quickly okay so how do you
implement this type of system in in
agile in startups and and I think even
in larger companies the implementation
strategy that you want to take when
you're building complex components is
that you always address the highest risk
components first so you have to do a
project assessment define the highest
risk components and then attack those
components first and get the data to
those components by hook or by crook
whatever you need to do to get the data
there so that you can start development
on that on the difficult pieces and then
once you know that the model is going to
perform really well the pipeline is
going to be very fast very performant
you're going to get the results that you
need then you can build out the rest of
the structure of the pipeline the
company is happy because they know that
at this point the ball you're just
rolling downhill okay so how did we
build this particular component the
pipeline we addressed it a little bit
differently usually usually in a project
there's really only one very high-risk
piece in this project there were two
high-risk pieces one was a newer
iteration of the adaptive locking model
then the newer iteration was written by
this data engineer here Romain Martin
he's currently living in Paris and he
was one of my first hires at Rhianna me
and we had an absolutely wonderful time
building this together and he's
completely impressive totally awesome
adapt adapt
locking model we started building on a
data set of that was big but not so big
that you had a long run time before the
cluster became so imbalanced with some
kinds of crazy edge cases where you have
enormous portfolios of certain entities
owning like an enormous number of
properties or you have some weird cases
of fraud that are creating some bizarre
edge cases that Bork the cluster so we
started with Rhode Island Rhode Island
is a great size so he started working on
Rhode Island I was working on a smaller
created test case and then he moved to
working on the entire country and then I
moved to working on Rhode Island and
once there were there was really good
performance for both of these components
we moved to the next phase and worked on
the integration right so this is fitting
the pieces together doing repartition
assure that checkpointing is happening
in the right places and one of the
reasons that we made for example like
there are two phases and the ML
classification models when you are so
that so addressing these two components
separately like working on the model it
just tells you about the performance of
the model it doesn't tell you about the
recall of the blocking algorithm that
came before it so if the recog or rhythm
is block is dropping some things that
the model would choose then we find out
in this runtime and cluster tuning and
the metrics in this integration phase
right and there were certain things that
the model needed like we didn't
necessarily anticipate that we should
just completely blow up the number of
partitions - you got the model - it just
run really really quickly yeah right and
then the last piece is doing integration
with with our API and looking at the
data in the app having product look at
it
having soft software engineers
full-stack engineers look at it and make
sure that everything looks the way that
it needs to before we deploy okay so we
have our graph data just to take a step
to step back we're building our property
intelligence we use some public data we
use a lot of private data from different
sources for companies from different
sources for properties spatial data we
have some sources of client data we're
doing build-out of an enterprise product
that integrates client data in a
separate system but it's the behavior
you could the search behavior accounts
for information from the client data and
now that we have something that can
create a better view of the world of
commercial real estate we're in a good
position to start to build additional
things so really fascinating additional
pieces like some of these predictive
analytics that have been listed here
which properties are likely to sell
which properties are likely to be right
refinanced what a market trends look
like what a portfolios look like etc
okay so that is that's about everything
that I have this is who we are we're
connecting the world of commercial real
estate and we're unlocking insights and
opportunities for everyone and I'm
Maureen thank you
[Applause]
[Music]